[Musique]
c'est une journée un peu particulière
pour la caserne d'achat finborg les
pompiers allemands vont poser
aujourd'hui devant l'appareil de Fredo
Fredo c'est le photographe des Dieux du
stade et de plein d'autres calendriers
il est spécialiste dans l'art de
photographier le corps des hommes
[Musique]
ça y est on rejoint Fred Goudon alors
Fred il y a besoin de quoi pour un
shooting alors il faut des flashs du
matériel qui est là et puis tous les
pompiers qui sont en train de se mettre
en place donc on a fait un petit un
petit discours de bienvenue ça s'est
bien passé et après ça on va commencer à
ajouter petit à petit les uns après les
autres individuellement pour leur donner
un petit peu l'idée de ce que ça donne
et puis pour moi aussi avoir une idée de
leur photogénie et puis après on va
enchaîner sur les photos de groupe etc
bon laisse Fred se préparer et puis nous
on va aller mettre une tenue un petit
peu plus adaptée
[Musique]
ça y est maintenant on est dans le thème
c'est l'heure de la traditionnelle photo
de groupe
ok Google
alors une belle photo de groupe
ouais c'est ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose ils font ils font corps on voit
que ils sont tous en place et en plus
ils se connaissent bien et donc je pense
que ça se ça se voit là mais ça se verra
encore plus à l'image
Corentin à toi maintenant à moi de jouer
[Musique]
est-ce que tout le monde est photo
génique non la photogénie c'est vraiment
ses propres à chacun et alors des fois
il y a des gens ça ils sont très beaux
et ils rentrent pas du tout à la photo
et puis des fois c'est l'inverse où les
gens sont un peu disgracieux peut-être
ou en tout cas et on dirait pas mais
quelquefois ça rend vraiment très très
bien à l'image donc peut-être que vous
voyez là moi je suis très photogénique
j'aime vraiment faire ce shooting le
photographe est vraiment cool et nous
nous amusons beaucoup ensemble avec tout
le groupe les photos sont incroyables de
ce qu'on a déjà pu voir
au total ce sont près de 1500 photos qui
ont été prises aujourd'hui il va falloir
faire des choix et puis les sélectionner
pour pouvoir les exposer au public
prochainement en France